我々人類は強くなりすぎてしまったようじゃ
我々に倒せない敵はおらん
そう思っとったんじゃなそういうわけでもないようじゃ
この男は己の肉体を最大限まで鍛え
その敵を倒そうとしている男所
誰のタンチョウは
風よりも光よりも速くなっ
[音楽]
ani
the がその中組でも勝つことができん
音はれとるんや8月
6世一60分
deni
じゃあ今回彼は
その人類最大のっていう
ある方法で倒そうとしておるんじゃなぁ
yeah
かもよああいう理由だけで行くぞ
これはマジか広い河原が入ってるなぁ
これ瓦の方々なんですけども実際にはれるらしいですよ
いつ何種類かありましてでもちょっとまり方も書いてありますちゃんとはいる瓦です
ツイッターやってみるわ
いきます
まじか普通2言われちゃんとでーっ
これで終わりじゃんコレだけどこれカラフルな瓦がたくさんあるんですけど
空振るじゃない瓦も縁あって惚れとかかなぁコンクリートブロッカーで釣ってるよこれ
この色の変わるだったらなんか本物っぽく見えるんじゃねっていう気がしてるんですよ
コレダメっちゃった目で見よった本物の瓦割ってぽく見えるんじゃない説があるんです
よね
[音楽]
ん
8番やばいやん萌え今明田人が桜
[音楽]
いっ
ん
[音楽]
いやいややばいやばいやばいあのああ
power core 売買はいはい変わら100万円を重ねました皆さんのが高さな
のに
治療も3万円台かかってんですよね集めるの一部などの養殖ぐらいあってこれ一番普通
の彼は乱歩色を集めるのがすごく大変でしたねまたパターン連れてっ
ような
どれだよねうん
めっちゃ傾いてるように見えるんだけど気のせ
ふぅ
さぁ次の工程な次はいかに算定ように本物っぽく見せるために染めのようにもってたに
本物っぽく瓦が積めるかですね
高校が一番重要になっていますちょっともミスは許されません頑張って行きたいと思い
ますこれ何かサメで釣りだとかいう方がいらっしゃると思うんですけど
商品名が変わらなんだこれ変わらないですよで嘘と言えばうそなんですけども品
とといえば本当なんですよね
べき場所が出来ましたやばいまずちょっとイヤーでは今前にゾールぬ
車いいでございます
本当に行かないこれが彼はヘッドがいいです皆さんこれがこれが変わりたくないです
パーッ
[音楽]
だーっ
いいえ
ああああああ
[音楽]
わっ
ai
me
dea
uh
[音楽]